hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex legends again
and today we have some interesting info
that was just leaked from the data files
talking about the new season 2 hero
Watson from apex legends and possibly
what the new trap ability that she or he
has called be tesla so as always like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new my Twitter and discord will
be in the description if you guys want
to join those and let's get started now
this leak has been found by gaming
intel.com I will leave the link to them
in the description as well as this post
of course well thank you Gaming Intel as
always for the latest news on the leaks
and the data files but there was a new
patch that came out today and there was
a few bug fixes some cool changes but of
course with every bug fix usually comes
some type of new leak that's hidden in
the files now the new ability as
described by the games files is going to
be called something about electric fence
and it comes with two different types of
models one that looks like some type of
mine and another one that kind of looks
like a pole there's really no concrete
in factual evidence on what this actual
ability is and what it does but my
assuming is that it's a mine that
actually ends up shooting up into the
sky that which warms the pole if a enemy
happens to go near the trap and then
maybe that can make the electrical type
of Tesla trap or some type of fence that
it makes I'm not actually sure but
that's what I think it will be in the
files right next to the name of it it
says something about death Tesla trap
and perimeter security so this might
also be some type of Defense character
which makes a lot of sense he is that
this person does have to do with traps
and my assumption is that instead of it
being like caustic where it's like
little mines place throughout the place
you basically can like box yourself in
and type of an electrical fence to give
your that little area some more coverage
as just instead of placing the traps
speaking of caustic I really hope that
this actually does not affect teammates
just like caustics ability it's one of
the huge problems I have with him in
general is that yes his traps can be
pretty effective in finding where the
enemy team is but it also affects
everyone in the map teammate or not
regardless which is really annoying to
me and it's also costing me a few
battles that I could have won if I could
see straight but I think it would be
really nice if we could have this type
of ability where you can lock down an
area of the map and nothing too big of
course probably like a small little box
that you can make so that maybe people
can't come in this could totally be
paired up with lifelines or anybody
reviving depending on health
the walls are if they're even holes you
could shoot from because I'm what you
could do is trap the electrical fence
around lifeline lifeline goes for the
revive using her shield is covered you
can get up your teammate pretty quickly
so I think that'd be a really nice tip
to be using for this if that is true I
myself am personally pretty excited for
Watson if this does actually come true
and if this character is supposed to be
the new character we're playing my only
issue is that I really wish that Watson
was not a defense character as the
leaked subset currently in the game we
have nine legends and his two defense
Gibraltar encaustic with one tracker
being blood hound to support speeding
Pathfinder and lifeline and the other
four are assault characters we have yet
to get another tracker and I originally
thought that was going to be the first
new character was to get a new tracker
so that they could at least get some
more people in that section especially
because there is an achievement to win a
game as a tracker and I think that
having more trackers would be really
nice to have for the part of the game
but that's just personally my opinion I
really do wish one of these days we will
get a type of tracker character I just
hope that it comes sooner rather than
later but that's just personally me
maybe it's just a little bit biased
because I play a lot of bloodhound but I
don't know let me know your thoughts on
that
hey guys gonna be the end of the VTA I
hope you guys did enjoy let me know your
thoughts on this new trap ability of
what this could be what you think it's
gonna be like do you think just based
off of this do you think Watson could be
a viable character anything about this
character any of your thoughts that
you've taken from this video I'd love to
know just leave them in the comments
below I'll be sure to respond but with
that like the V if you do enjoy
subscriber for new my two most recent
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
you guys want to check those out couple
them are lore videos and thank you guys
for so more support on the octane
backstory video it's almost reaching
500,000 views and with that peace out
guys have a great rest your day and
enjoy
[Music]
you